Oh, it’s almost there, it’s almost there!
Ooooh!
This has to be one of the most phenomenal,
astronomical events that you can see with
your naked
eye. I mean, I’m just looking at the sun
right now. Ohh,
it got a little bit brighter around the edge.
MUSIC
Well we are here at the University of Nottingham,
in
Nottingham, but we are getting ready to jump
on a
couple of planes to go to China so that we
can still be at
the University of Nottingham.
Well there happens to be a total solar eclipse
that’s
happening in just a little over a day, and
it passes, the
path of totality, passes right over the University
of
Nottingham in Ningbo, China. At the moment
it looks
like it is going to be cloudy, so I am really,
really hoping
that the clouds are not with us.
Give us a smile
LAUGHS
Hello!
AIRPORT ANNOUNCEMENT
MUSIC
The forecast looks very grim. It seems that
there is a
front moving in tomorrow morning…it doesn’t
look good.
MUSIC
So here we are in China at the University
of Nottingham,
Ningbo Campus. We finally arrived. And so
we are
anticipating this big solar eclipse tomorrow,
while we
are watching occasional lightning bolts. Quite
on cue,
right there. They just cover the entire half
of the sky, in
the direction where the sun is actually supposed
to rise
tomorrow morning, where we are going to see
this
fantastic astronomical event. Maybe! So I
am still
keeping my hopes up but, I am not positive
that we are
actually going to be able to see it.
MUSIC
We have been travelling for two days, two
and a half, I
forget what day it is at the moment, but I
know that
tomorrow morning at 9:37 am local time…
LAUGHS
is when the big event happens.
MUSIC
Well its 4:54am and we just came out to see
what the
sky looks like and to see what the potential
is for the
solar eclipse this morning and it doesn’t
look very good.
Not very promising indeed.
BIRD CHIRPS
Beautiful, but not good for a sun … for
a solar event
MUSIC
We went out for the sunrise this morning and
the
weather did not look terribly fantastic but
after a little
break and a cup of tea we came back out again
to see
the clouds not quite so thick and we can actually
see the
sun up there, so what I have right here is
my very own
solar filter that I made. This is a roll of
black and white
film. Now it has to be actually black and
white and not
the colour film that they just develop black
and white
but real black and white film. So you expose
it to the
sun and then you send it off to be developed
and then it
has this nice layer of sliver on there that
acts as a filter
for the ultra violet and the infra red that’s
the most
damage… most harmful for your eyes. But
we have a
good chance of actually getting a solar eclipse.
Ok, now
I am really excited!
LAUGHS
Yeah! In ten maybe! Ten minutes!
MAN REPLIES IN CHINESE
Ten minutes it will cover!
MUSIC
So we have just reached the first contact
point and
that’s when the edge of the moon first touches
the edge
of the sun, so it is now just starting to
pass in front of it.
We have about an hour now until the total
eclipse phase
starts. So it’s the sun, moon and earth
in a straight line.
The moon actually covers the sun. Well it
might seem
slow, it takes the moon a while to cover the
sun
completely but actually the shadow of the
moon is
barrelling across the surface of the earth
at about 2,000
miles per hour. I am fascinated by the idea
of what
ancient people thought when the sun just completely
went away. There are different stories about
how they
reacted. The ancient Chinese in fact, thought
that
dragons were attacking the sun and they were
going to
eat it and take it away so what they decided
to do was
just to make noise, beat drums, scream, make
as much
noise as they could to get rid of the moon
and to keep
the sun and so luckily every time that actually
happened
and they got the sun back.
LAUGHS
MAN SPEAKS IN CHINESE
Well people have just decided to gather to
watch, they
have been using some of our solar eclipse
glasses and
the kids are playing with feathers, they don’t
really know
what’s going on. They think the sun looks
like the
crescent moon, or they keep saying “I see
the crescent
moon”. Because the moon is actually covering
the sun.
Yeah.
MAN SPEAKS IN CHINESE
So normally when the sun goes down the animals
start
to go back to their burrows and go to sleep
and so right
now they start to, they look like they are.
The birds are
kind of going away. There are small little
floaty things
that are leaving and the ducks just started
to go hide in
the trees, but a couple of kids went and yelled
at them
so they did not really know what to do.
LAUGHS
Oh it’s fantastic.
Oh, it’s almost there, it’s almost there!
Ooohh! Wow!
LAUGHS
Oh my gosh!
Oh my gosh. This has to be one of the coolest
things I
have ever seen. You can see the corona glowing
around
the sun and the temperature just dropped completely
and everyone started cheering
LAUGHS
It’s amazing!
I completely didn’t think we were going
to be able to see
it like that. Fireworks are going off
LAUGHS
You could see a little bit of red at the very
edge where
the …. where we could see the last bit of
light. It’s
amazingly dark. When I look through my binoculars
I
can actually see some of the outer ring, some
of the
corona sort of flickering and I don’t think
that is entirely
due to the clouds. I actually think that has
to do with the
light coming out.
Oh man, that is the coolest, coolest!
I mean can you imagine, even thousands of
years ago
seeing something like this and having any
idea what was
going on. You can hear people yelling in the
distance,
screaming and cheering.
LAUGHS
Oh my gosh! If we could actually see, if there
weren’t
any clouds. Oh we can, there’s Venus. Hey
there’s
Venus!
So we can see the planet Venus right there
really bright.
And if we could see the clouds around the
sun we would
be able to see Mercury. Yeah! This is amazing,
this is
amazing! The clouds are coming in a little
bit more now
so you can’t see it quite as well but…
How does this rate on your astronomy experiences?
I mean, even with the clouds this has to be
one of the
most phenomenal astronomical events that you
can see
with your naked eye. I mean I’m just looking
at the sun
right now. Ohh it got a little bit brighter
around the
edge.
Ohh! And it just doesn’t happen very often
in each spot
on the earth.
Oh my gosh!
It just popped back out! That was a quick
four minutes I
have to tell ya!
LAUGHS
So the sun just popped back out on the other
side of the
moon so it is brighter again instantly so
I am wrapping a
foil around our camera so we can actually
look at it
again and now I have to use these.
The next total solar eclipse will be in about
one year
from now, its July 11th, 2010 and it will
go past, it will
go over Easter Island and Chile and some of
Argentina,
so I have to figure out a good reason to go
down there.
LAUGHS
So, a University of Nottingham campus, Easter
Island
maybe?
We are just sitting here glowing with the
enjoyment of
what we just saw! It’s amazing, that four
and a half
minutes went so quickly! Wow!